tonight on the new reality there's no
such thing as zero risk will offices
ever be the same you get it to a point
where people can feel comfortable coming
back into your building the kovat
business boom right now one of the chief
things that consumers want is a safer
experience our hope is that Canadians
will support local the new reality of
fitness even those who didn't experience
that anxiety going into a gym may now
experience it virtual family visits we
talk every day many times a day hey I
live for that and new Parenthood in a
pandemic with Colvin one of the hardest
things is that there isn't somebody else
to hand him off to it's just the two of
us
[Music]
hello and welcome to the new reality I'm
Donna Friesen we try to look at every
aspect of our life that's changed
because of the pandemic and one of the
biggest is how we work those of us lucky
enough to still have a job have had to
adapt we're getting the work done from
our kitchens or our couches pajamas are
the new business suit what's that done
though to the millions of square meters
of office space around the world much of
it is empty now and it could stay that
way for a long time Jackson Prosecco
explores the future of offices in a
building in Falls Church Virginia
we found what may be the workplace of
the future an office retrofitted and
ready for the era of kovat 19 at least
that's the hope people have seen some of
the things that we're doing and they
want to incorporate it into their
offices as well christian Pinkston has
been working to get his company prepared
for it's uncertain next steps figuring
out what it will take to welcome staff
back into the office the concept of just
a deeper cleaning once or twice a day
isn't going to be enough and because
once you bring people back into the
spaces it's instantly contaminated again
in the US and Canada there are few
guidelines for how offices should
operate in a pandemic
so Pinkston developed his own playbook
taking a gamble on technology starting
with this ultraviolet cleanse portal the
new front door they'll go through this
portal kind of slowly they'll pause
they'll do a slow turn there making sure
that all that you know the surfaces of
their hands and in clothes are exposed
to the UV lighting and so it's it's
cleansing them of any microbes viruses
bacteria they might be carrying with
them and anything they're carrying as
well so if I step into this I mean I'm
not seeing anything there's a little bit
of like a faint a faint light and a
faint sound
but that's it that purple glow is UVC
light known for its germ zapping
abilities Pinkston has also installed
UVC fixtures in high-traffic areas like
the kitchen along with specialized air
filters we know that Karuna virus will
spread through the air droplets and so
that's a major risk factor and so we've
installed an air sanitizing troffer in
this room that's constantly
recirculating the air and and with a
very powerful UVC light inside of it
then there are the invisible changes
special sensors detect if there's virus
in the air every surface is now covered
in an antimicrobial coating of titanium
dioxide we wanted to do something that
was realistic financially but we wanted
to do as much as we could within that
parameter to provide the safest possible
environment the reality is that offices
are the kind of places where Cove ignite
team can thrive full of shared surfaces
close quarters and long days of
uncontrolled contact researchers in
South Korea discovered how easily the
virus can spread in that environment
after a cluster of 97 employees at a
call center in Seoul tested positive for
kovat 19 when health officials looked
closer they found 94 of them work
together on the same floor and 79 of
them sat in the same section of the
office nearly half of the workers on
that one floor ended up getting sick to
make sure that doesn't happen again
offices and office buildings will have
to take drastic steps from top to bottom
Professor Joseph Allen is an expert in
healthy buildings we have to employ some
of these healthy building strategies
like bringing more fresh outdoor air to
dilute the airborne contaminants and
filter the recirculated air using
high-efficiency filters that's just one
small part of a multi-layered defense
desks will have to be spaced at least
two metres apart high-walled cubicles
may have to make a comeback employees
and visitors will be subjected to
temperature checks don't be surprised if
everyone
to wear a mask kitchens and common areas
will likely be off-limits even the
little things like pictures and trinkets
on desks will likely disappear to make
way for daily deep cleaning if you layer
enough defenses on top of each other you
make it really difficult in this case of
security for a bad actor to penetrate
your system right same thing with this
virus if you layer enough of these
defenses on top of each other you don't
eliminate risk there's no such thing as
zero risk you get it to a point where it
can become manageable and to a level
where people can feel comfortable coming
back into your building the elevator may
be the biggest hurdle there's just no
way around it expect a limit on how many
people can ride at a time and then
imagine what that means in a building
like New York's One World Trade Center
where 8,000 workers are spread across 90
floors and so the easiest solution may
just be for companies to keep some
people working from home
staggering shifts or alternating days to
have fewer people in the office at any
given time I think one thing that it has
taught people is that you can remote you
can work remotely and you can do it
effectively now the things you can't do
effectively I think that's what we're
gonna lean on the office for Albert day
plays Ola is the director of global
strategy for the design firm unis base
he sees kovat 19 changing the role of
the office forever Canadian tech giant
Shopify has already declared the era of
office centricity is over employees will
stay working from home until 2021 after
that the office will be for specific
uses only not an everyday destination
twitter has gone even further telling
staff they can work from home forever if
they want to now we've done a ton of
surveys with organizations we're getting
a lot of we get we're getting a lot of
feedback and input from CFOs and what
we're saying is that at least forty to
sixty percent of employees want to work
from home even if there is a vaccine one
two three days a week for all the
precautions he's taken Christian
Pinkston has found there's not actually
much enthusiasm among his staff for
returning to the office and we did an
anonymous
survey of our staff a couple of weeks
ago and I was shocked by what I found
they were not ready to come back and
there was still a lot of uncertainty a
lot of fear there's very much still
avoiding any unnecessary contact with
people that aren't you know family any
plan to get employees back to their
desks will have to include plenty of
reassurance a communication plan to let
people know what's being done to keep
them safe and flexibility to let them
decide when they're ready to come back
once we're opening the office to staff
it'll be on a as you're comfortable
basis will be sending out alerts when
clients or outsiders will be in the
office we're going to be having staff
monitoring their temperatures and
symptoms and making decisions on a
day-by-day basis as to whether it's safe
for them to come in so lots of
communication and some confusion for
both employers and employees about when
to go back and how to go back who needs
a shake is a labor and employment lawyer
with Levitt LLP and she's in Richmond
Hill Ontario Manisa thanks for joining
us returning to work in a pandemic is
new ground for all of us what
obligations broadly do employers have
when it comes to bringing staff back
into the office can they just say we
need you back and expect you to show up
well they can certainly say say to their
employees that they want you back and we
need you back but ultimately whether or
not employees have an obligation to show
up is largely dependent on how safe the
workplace is now I will tell you that
employers have to follow much of the
very same guidelines that we're watching
on TV as they come down the pipeline
through the provincial government and
direction from the federal government
around social distancing where possible
and sometimes with certain jobs as you
know it isn't possible and providing
appropriate protective gear when social
distancing is not possible so unless
employers really understand that they
need to step up to the challenge and do
their best to keep their employees safe
simply telling them to return to return
to work given this current pandemic is
not enough
what about employee rights can people be
forced back to the office if they feel
it's not safe or they're uncomfortable
about it so while your employer has an
obligation to keep you safe and healthy
in the workplace an employer does not
have an obligation to accommodate your
stress worrier angst because let's be
honest given the nature of this pandemic
and given much of what we've come to
learn in the past few weeks and months
you know there is no guarantee that you
will be fully insulated from this virus
so as long as your employer meets that
reasonable threshold in terms of keeping
you safe whether it's through social
distancing or protective gear may be
working from remotely in a staggered way
a lot of companies are doing that I know
our firm is doing that unless you know
as long as they are meeting that
threshold simply telling your employer
that look I understand that you're doing
all of these things but I'm still
worried I still don't want to come into
the workplace that simply is not good
enough from the employee perspective and
you could very well be faced with the
risk of being told by your employer that
because we have done everything that we
understand we need to do your refusal to
come in to work at this point would
either be considered to be a resignation
or a job abandonment if that reasonable
threshold isn't reached though if
employees find that hygiene isn't
sufficient or physical distancing is
lacks are they stuck then or what can
they reasonably do at that point
they absolutely aren't stuck although I
can appreciate from a positional power
perspective that it's really difficult
to walk up to your employer and say hey
you know you're saying you're doing the
right things but I'm actually here and
it seems like you aren't in those
circumstances the employees most
certainly can file a complaint under the
Occupational Health and Safety Act I
know some of the Labor Relations
officers or ministry of labor officers
are responding pretty promptly to these
complaints that can be made anonymously
and they will come and check the
workplace out to see if indeed it's only
lip service or you know has the employer
actually implemented you know the social
distancing the protective gears and in
some cases it might be something as
simple as
you know putting up signs and reminders
to employees and you know in the
lunchroom perhaps or other areas where
employees tend to congregate reminding
them that social distancing is to be
observed at all times let's talk about
parents working from home who are
juggling work duties and looking after
young kids if they don't have access to
childcare schools not back for example
is that a legitimate reason to say I
can't come back to the office yet
it absolutely is a legitimate reason
under the human rights legislation there
is a protected ground which speaks to an
accommodation as far as it might relate
to family status and so if you as an
employer and many of my clients I've
said this to me have you know your
employees who are parents calling you
and saying look I understand that you're
not offering a remote option but under
no circumstances can I come back into
the workplace because I don't have
childcare in those circumstances what
you could expect is a job protective
leave that would be unpaid so your job
is safe but the employer has no
obligation to pay you if you are home
with your kids this is as I said new
ground for all of us do you expect that
there'll be lots of test cases of
employment law as this endemic continues
absolutely and what we have been saying
to our clients whether they are employer
clients or whether there are employee
quiet clients is this is unchartered
territory for so many of us including
employment lawyers so notwithstanding
the fact that you know we are giving
certain legal advice weaves Chane we've
seen just a couple weeks ago certain
legislative changes and I think some of
these test cases from an employment law
perspective in the coming months are
really going to map out for us what an
accommodation looks like what the
employers obligations are during a
pandemic and most importantly what is
that reasonable test in terms of keeping
employees safe in the workplace those
are specific areas where I expect there
to be a significant amount of legal
narrative which could very well change
the advice some of the advice that we
give to our clients
the pandemic has been a huge hit to our
economy and thousands of businesses have
lost customers for others though there
is a silver lining in Canada the vast
majority of businesses are small and
medium sized they employ most of the
workers in the private sector small and
medium-sized businesses contribute 55
percent of Canada's GDP the pandemic
ground almost everything to a halt just
look at the number of jobs lost in early
2020 for example well in May some signs
of hope the economy added 290 thousand
new jobs some business owners are
actually thriving because of this
pandemic and they can barely keep up
with demand Mike la Couture has the
stories of some of them they are the
literal and figurative signs of the
times
everywhere you go these days you're
directed where to stand how to move
around a business my taped arrows and
decals interaction with sales staff is
kind of face to face you don't count
that Plexiglas barrier the virus is
unpredictable so - or the spin-off
industries are helping us cope with
kovat 1910 weeks ago 12 weeks ago it was
pandemonium inaction has leveled off
somewhat at this glass manufacturer in
Ottawa the height of the pandemic the
demand for plexiglass was way beyond
anything Tom Zhukov had seen after 40
years in the business there has never
ever been anything like this where all
of a sudden at the snap of fingers this
had to happen immediately there was no
gradual climbing of a hill there was no
production thoughts there was nothing it
just happened in melee and it had to
happen now or so they started making
three sizes that could stand alone and
be a barrier to protect essential
workers business is still brisk
it's just as busy at Miller McConnell
signs but that wasn't the case at the
beginning of the pandemic when the
Ottawa marathon and other major events
were canceled so too were the contracts
to supply all those signs had the
acrylic in-house that quickly shifted to
making face shields it was definitely we
wanted to help out the community because
we were in a position to provide this
much needed PPE but a part of it was
also trying to keep as many people
employed as possible also donating
hundreds to community organizations and
other communities in the far north a
weeks ago when provinces started to ease
restrictions the core business bounced
back changing times meant a different
type of sign is now needed you've
probably already seen those floor decals
in nearly every store or business you've
been to lately telling people where to
stand and helping them to keep us safe
physical distance if you've been pitched
these kid-friendly concepts to the City
of Ottawa for municipal facilities State
cares start opening up in camps and and
all that sort of stuff there's gonna be
fun colors with pictures of animals
numbers you know go sit on this
butterfly or whatnot that kind of
forward thinking is helping some
businesses boom while others go bust
during the kovat nineteen crisis now the
Canadian economy reopens businesses are
the orienting it's believed that will
also help us get through the recovery
even as the threat of the coronavirus
remains small businesses are guided
largely by what consumers want and right
now one of the chief things that
consumers want is a safer experience
when they're out there doing their daily
errands and their important shopping why
we're being bombarded on social media by
ads for gadgets that'll keep us safe
from kovat 19 the phone sanitizer the
endless variety of anti German cos their
effectiveness remains unproven but
personal protective equipment is in
demand and there is increasing pressure
to localize supply chains Canada isn't
forced to rely on other countries we
have the technology
we have the ingenuity we have the
engineering light the manufacturing
might there's nothing we can't build
right here in Ontario enter Alex dugal
who's going all in on medical masks not
gonna lie it's probably one of the
scariest business ideas I've ever come
up with scary because it cost half a
million dollars up front he imported the
mask making machine from China so people
in this country will stop buying masks
from that country our hope is that
Canadians and governments and businesses
will support local and if our material
and our finished product is a comparable
price to what they were paying before
that they'll consider small thing over
to a Canadian company to buy that
product his idea is to move beyond basic
blue into more colors and even
customizable for corporate logos he's
hoping to roll out these for Canada
today Dougal also believes the
uncertainty around covert 19 means masks
will be a mainstay eventually when
everyone gets back to going a big group
events more than likely they're gonna
need a face covering so our thought is
is that we've got that group of buyers
but also at the end of the day
healthcare needs these year round coming
up this is the most unusual of stressful
events perhaps ever understanding crisis
fatigue it leaves us feeling very
depleted in our ability to cope the
short and long-term effects of the
pandemic on our brains and I've worked
out all my life the future of fitness
there's long-standing research to show
that there's a relationship between
physical activity events all staying
motivated under lockdown and the new
reality of exercising
pandemic life is pretty static a lot of
us have never had so much time at home
much of it spent sitting waiting some
gyms and pools and spinning studios are
beginning to open with big modifications
of course we asked Liam vu to delve into
the challenges and opportunities facing
the fitness industry with so many
Canadians anxious to resume their
workouts three months ago the fitness
industry was booming generating one
hundred and twenty seven point four
billion dollars globally and then the
new reality
Cobin 19 forced gyms around the world to
close pushing the health and wellness
industry into a vast unknown while
Canadians scrambled to find ways to stay
fit under lockdown
[Music]
lissa Balestra is a sixty-year-old
financial consultant who is pushing back
against the pandemic she goes on daily
walks and runs and every other day
dedicates two hours to strength training
I've worked out all my life so at
different stages of my life I had
different reasons why to work out when I
was younger was more of a competitive
after children it was more to stay in
shape and keep up with the kids 4050 the
aches and pains were coming she has no
choice but to keep moving she's living
with arthritis a herniated disc and
spinal stenosis which can trigger
excruciating pain in her neck I find
that if I don't exercise the pain will
start again when you're in pain and
constant pain I think it's such a mental
toll on you and it can put you into into
depression high anxiety a recent poll
found thirty percent of Canadians were
feeling anxiety about the pandemic
triggering other issues with 29 percent
saying they're overeating the same
number also reporting a lack of exercise
there's a long-standing research to show
that there's a relationship between
physical activity and mental health
being more active improves mood symptoms
of depression symptoms of anxiety we
can't really fight the research anymore
on that and it's not just everyday
Canadians struggling to find motivation
celebrities they're just like us
actor Bill Murray partnered up with his
local gym to promote their at home
workouts a service many studios started
to offer Holly reikus is a former TV
producer who took a leap of faith two
years ago and opened a 7,000 square foot
fitness facility in Toronto before the
lockdown the studio offered 16 classes
serving several hundred members on a
daily basis the pandemic required
pivoting renting out weights and leading
workouts online it was about finding
connection in a physically distant world
of course it's different to teach people
online than it is teach them in person
however I think we need to take a minute
to reflect on how privileged and lucky
we are to be in a time where we can
still
connect with people face-to-face and of
course another really amazing benefit of
the virtual world that we've kind of
discovered is that we can serve more
people from you know more places farther
away and while there's no shortage of
motivation online finding fitness gear
continues to be an exercise in patience
and endurance last March in the US
retail sales for training equipment
surged by 130 percent compared to last
year
that demand simply exceeding the supply
the last month or two the supplies have
been very low because our suppliers have
run out of inventory they're very close
to catching up and a lot of our
shipments are coming in now so we'll be
able to fulfill the hundreds of orders
that we've been getting turns out the
supply chain for fitness equipment
especially free weights had the same
vulnerabilities as personal protective
equipment most of it made overseas
making them hard to get during a
worldwide pandemic but necessity is the
mother of invention and so many
Canadians have adapted finding unique
ways and objects to work out with select
gyms reopened across Canada in early
June like Club 16 in BC with new
protocols and reduced capacity meanwhile
gyms in Toronto remain closed but an
upcoming yoga event is still pushing
ahead allowing participants to step out
of their at-home bubble into another one
but the fitness industry may never be
the same
we know one of the main barriers to
people exercising is the fear of going
into a gym in the first place you know
what where you look where do you go
where that what kind of equipment do you
use even those who didn't experience
that anxiety going into a gym may now
experience it for some individuals will
be very anxiety-provoking
addressing physical and mental health is
something that gyms will have to tackle
once doors reopen in some cases doors
that never opened in the first place
tribe space yoga was set to open in the
spring but Kovan 19 put a pause on the
poses owner Jordanna Ricketts
acknowledges the lockdown could bankrupt
her but says Canadians will eventually
need more than just a physical reset
they'll need a mental one after months
of isolation when you appeal to their
sites the sounds with the music and the
smells with the incense
saij that we have burning at all times
here all of those factors combined is
really what's gonna draw people here and
really get them to feel that feeling of
relaxation leasable essary finds that
calm by working out it's not just the
physical necessity it's also a way for
her to stay connected to her late father
these are a special way they're my dad's
weight so they've been in my basement as
a child you know he had a lot of
physical challenges in his later years
right but you know what he was out there
walking she is unsure if she will ever
step back into a gym she's just happy to
continue being active blazing her own
trail of course not everyone has been
able to go down that path in the four
months that Kovac 19 has upended our
lives physically it's also had a
tremendous impact on us psychologically
a poll by Angus Reed found 31% of
Canadians said they feel worn-out and
fatigued 28% feel anxious 22% said
they're worried and only 16% said they
feel normal
what is always stress doing to our
brains
Susan wit Bourne is here with some
insight she's a professor of
psychological and brain sciences at the
University of Massachusetts and she
joins us from just outside Boston hi
there you know I've heard lots of
anecdotes about people being tired and
distracted and having trouble sleeping
but what is this pandemic actually doing
to our brains and are we wired to cope
with a crisis that has no end in sight
this is the most unusual of stressful
events perhaps ever although of course
there have been previous pandemics and
there have been Wars I mean there's all
kinds of traumatic events people have
lived through this one is different
because it is global it is uncertain in
terms of its ending and it leaves us
with really feeling very depleted in our
ability to cope so is there such a thing
as crisis fatigue or Quarantine fatigue
in' and how does it manifest itself in
our brains in our bodies we've never
seen this kind of fatigue there's
something called compassion fatigue
which we're
seeing of course in healthcare workers
and mental health workers as well as
just a really strong source of burnout
but for the average person
quarantine fatigue is just something we
don't even know what to do with so the
natural response is to give up and I
think what makes that it makes it harder
to keep the energy going to remain
vigilant is that it seems to be getting
better in places that have been
practicing good public health so people
say oh well I don't need to worry them
because the trend is going down but the
trend is going down because people are
complaining and when they don't the
trend spike so there's that and then
there's this distance of yourself from
the actual stressor which again is
somewhat similar to war terrorism in all
of the stressful events that everybody
goes through but this one it unless it
struck you or your family somebody you
work with a neighbor it doesn't feel
quite real and the stress both fear of
the virus and and financial uncertainty
for a lot of people who have lost their
jobs can that affect your cognitive
abilities yes it can cortisol is the
stress hormone and we know that cortisol
is supposed to show sort of a peak in
the morning and then go down throughout
the day peak again on the next morning
but what stress does is it actually
ironically flattens that curve which is
not a good curve to flatten people who
are under prolonged psychological stress
show a flattening of their diurnal or
daily variations in cortisol and that
impairs their health long term what are
some of the signs that someone is
becoming overwhelmed huge stress
manifests as nightmares even trembling
you know a very low mood you know great
deal of anxiety and and so yeah you can
easily see people being stressed
but you can also see it in terms of
denial people use denial when they're
stressed it's a really natural way to
kind of fight off bad news so you might
see denial and that might be some of the
people who sort of minimize the whole
thing and say oh you know it's nothing
or I've survived or I don't need to
worry about this or why should I worry
about this so you can see both extremes
of people's ways of coping how about the
separation from loved ones who we'd
usually turn to in times of stress does
that make things worse and are there
actual physiological effects from
prolonged social isolation yes there are
and there's been a great deal of concern
a psychological community especially
with older adults which happens to be my
specialty and social isolation among
older adults is a problem in general but
it is exacerbated by the enforced social
isolations on the plus side though
people are resilient and older people
are resilient they've lived through a
lot so people are finding ways to
overcome the social isolation and I
think being very creative about it well
yeah and people are connecting virtually
like we are you know using FaceTime and
Skype and zoom is that really a
replacement for in-person contact or
does their body and our brain respond
differently to connecting that way the
body definitely responds to touching you
know touch has its own host of benefits
so you're missing out on that no denying
it so there's that but then the fact
that people are going out of their way
to surmount the physical distance then
can also be reassuring to people because
you might be getting calls from people
you otherwise wouldn't and maybe even on
a more regular basis because people are
checking in with you to see how you're
doing you think there could be a
long-term impact from this pandemic on
the psychological health of people I
definitely do and and it's interesting
you ask the question that way because
one of the things
my study is the effect of kind of
contact social context history on
psychological development so there will
be a pre kovat and a post Tobin reality
but humans are social animals we want to
get back together we want to overcome
this and we're resilient so we're going
to see changes some of them will be bad
but some of them might surprise us
because of the resilience that people
show still ahead a movement effect
staying connected using creativity and
technology to reinvent the hospital
visit and up next the app was telling us
to go to the hospital but we've heard
not to do that
having a baby during a pandemic we had
lots of time together to hunker down
just three of us a co bid nineteen
challenges for these first-time parents
[Music]
it's Father's Day so what better day to
bring you the sweet story of the couple
we've followed through their pandemic
pregnancy Carina and Elias are now
parents baby Anderson is their first he
was born about a month ago he's healthy
and well though his path into the world
did take a few turns babies don't care
about a global health crisis or worry if
it's the right time here's the new
reality of delivering in a pandemic I'm
Eli I'm Korean and he is Anderson and
this is our co vid birth story on Sunday
about a week after our due date I woke
up at 2:00 a.m. because my contractions
were getting much stronger so I started
tracking them and they were about five
minutes apart so the app was telling us
to go to the hospital but we've heard
not to do that so we just called our
doula and she came by the next morning
to check in because of kobane we wanted
to stay home as long as possible
originally the plan was to have a
natural birth at the hospital but we
were also prepared to have the baby at
home if things were going smoothly
contractions were intense and consistent
from Sunday through Tuesday the longest
being six or seven minutes apart and the
shortest being one and a half we're
talking three days of contractions
Korean soldier Don throughout with the
support of our doula and regular
check-ins from the midwives labor was
progressing slowly but they warned us
things could escalate at any time I
guess I just I'm just
yeah it's hard to imagine another
by Tuesday morning Kareem was dilated 4
to 5 centimeters and the Midwife
suggested a castor oil cocktail to try
and speed things up naturally parsnip
cream took it twice but nothing
apparently she's impervious honestly she
was a champ through this whole thing
it's like interval training and we tried
everything so many different exercises
and listened to so much hypnobirthing my
blood pressure is always perfect and
stable on Tuesday night her water broke
but the dilation was about the same and
the baby wasn't in a great position on
the advice of our midwife we decided it
was time to head to the hospital for
some help 247 May 20th 2020 maybe's new
birth day we arrived
checked in and answer the Kovac
questions I take the long walk the labor
delivery floor so later Wednesday
morning things hadn't really progressed
and the baby was in an awkward position
his head was facing up into the right
they call these babies stargazers which
is a cute name but not good for delivery
nope
so around noon we made the call to move
ahead with a c-section we also didn't
want to risk Crean getting a fever
because then that unlocks all these
covert protocols which can involve
isolation and all these other tests and
ain't nobody got time to that they
ripped green for surgery coming back to
this with the baby I suited up and by
2:00 p.m. we were headed to do our with
the help of the exceptional team at the
BC Women's Hospital we welcomed a
beautiful little boy
oh it's a boy it's a boy the two days we
spent at the hospital in recovery were
really positive in part because of
coulded you got our own room because of
social distancing and with no visitors
allowed we had lots of time together to
hunker down just the three of us
if nurses close by should we have any
questions one nurse even mentioned an
increase in successful breastfeeding
during kovat because of the lack of
interruptions but we were ready to come
home your home
since then anderson has been pretty
great for the most part we loved his
smiles and not startle reflex i love
watching him stare at himself in the
mirror and the face he makes when i hit
it with the hairdryer
i love the way he looks at us and the
way kareem looks at him as she serenades
him to sleep but it's not all rainbows
and lollipops sometimes he's just fussy
and he won't stop crying it's kind of
like battling an internet troll you see
there's no reasoning with them because
facts don't matter
also we're sleeping less and then he'll
just be on you with Co bed one of the
hardest things is that there isn't
somebody else to hand him off to it's
just the two of us yeah I mean he's one
month old and besides medical
appointments it's only Korean and I that
upheld him right bud you're stuck with
us before Kovac we were looking forward
to a summer of having friends and family
business people like my mom but
unfortunately those plans got cancelled
yeah now everybody just has to meet them
through video chat which is great but
obviously not the same luckily our
friends have been amazing with gifts and
meals and socially distanced visits so
we're definitely lucky having a kid is
always going to be challenging but in
2020 with Kovac the black lives matter
protests and the growing concerns we
already had over climate change there's
a lot going on in the old brain right
now
what's work and look like moving forward
where do we want to live who do we add
into our bubble we want to visit friends
and family but should we as a mix kid is
he gonna face some of the same
challenges I did growing up a visible
minority what kind of world are we gonna
leave him these are all some pretty big
questions and honestly sometimes can be
overwhelming but the time being we're
just taking it one day at a time
and trying to enjoy this crazy stage of
his life because we know it's gonna fly
by it's getting the snuggles enjoy all
the First's and try to support
organizations and idea the push things
forward in the end we all just want the
best for our kids and families
maybe 2020 is our pivot point we turn
things around I've always been pretty
motivated to do better now I have a
little more inspiration staring me right
in the face
next on the new reality virtual family
visits we talk every day many times a
day I live for that the hospital keeping
patients safe and connected during the
pandemic
[Music]
we're social beings were wired to
connect with other people and when human
contact is withdrawn it can have a
serious impact on physical and mental
health
that's especially so for patients
confined to hospitals strict visitor
policies are in place to limit the
spread of Coe bid 19 so some hospitals
have developed creative ways to keep
patients in touch with their loved ones
especially seniors who don't have the
technology to do it themselves when
Toronto Area Hospital allowed us to see
how its virtual family visit program
works
it was March 20th so that's when the
hospital instituted their limited family
cousins policy at the hospital at that
point we sort of mobilized a large group
of colleagues throughout the hospital to
create the program my name is Sara
Carney I work as the elder life
specialist here at the North York
General and I've been redeployed to work
as a facilitator in the virtual family
visits program when they come in and
couple days later which I was very very
shocked
I miss my favorite hi hi you know I
[Music]
change my mind we started thinking of
other things I think about him about
that soccer game in the scale of 10 I
put 9 plus we're gonna call Ileana okay
[Music]
[Applause]
even just seeing smile on their face or
the patient's face light up as soon as
they see their family members has been a
really rewarding
[Music]
Sara helped us to see mom pretty often
and the mom was responding to our
singing because she doesn't speak
English she doesn't understand English
especially because of that so it's good
for us because we can see how she does
and is good for her at the same time
because she actually sees the faces that
talk with us in our senior population
rates of delirium and functional as a
client are quite high and families are
really integral in helping those
patients not to develop delirium or
other problems in hospital my name is
Shawna Haberman I'm the patient and
family-centered care consultant for
North York General Hospital I was asked
to act as the lead on our virtual family
visit program the full donation was 100
iPads 50 of those iPads have been
earmarked for a general site and 50
iPads have been earmarked for our
seniors health center which is our
long-term care facility it's just over
600 patients who can benefit I know I
feel like I've been living a nightmare
since the middle of March he tested
positive and he had had a fever and he
wasn't really responsive
it was terrible like it was so scary I
thought I was in tears thankfully he
didn't have any respiratory problems and
in a few days he came around we talked
every day many times a day and I live
for that
you can't go on life without seeing
something you know or communicating the
phone isn't enough so good you're so
alert right now amazing
you're the best you're a tough lady
absolutely and everybody loves you all
the time she was loving and generous to
all of us
like my mom and all that our mom said no
longer life she's the only thing they
have thank you the baby I'm free ever
since I've started in this new role I
just find it so meaningful I find myself
thinking about these maybe it's part of
the family connection piece but even
when I'm not at work or thinking about
the patients here how they're doing and
thinking with their family members one
special lady I love her
[Music]
we'll be right back on the new reality
[Music]
that's our program for this week coming
up on the new reality as more people
begin to return to work we'll look at
the future of child care daycares can
reopen but with many restrictions how
will they survive and who will decide
who gets those precious spots also be
sees provincial health officer was one
of our first guests on the new reality
bonnie henry had lots of fans then and
even more now
she was profiled by the New York Times
as the doctor who a stacker oh no virus
tests I'll talk to her again about how
to make DC's success dealing with kovat
19 sustainable in the months ahead and
as always you can find more stories
about the new reality on our web site
global news dot CA slash the new reality
I'm Donna Friesen thanks for watching